Today we're going to talk about a very
specific drink that can help you unclog
your arteries. And this relates all the
consequences that happen when you have
damage to your arteries. High blood
pressure, clots that can develop that
can actually turn into a stroke and
heart attacks. Now, one of the problems
that people have when they go to the
doctor is the doctors don't really focus
on root causes. They're looking at
things later on the chain of events like
high blood pressure, like high
cholesterol, and then they treat those,
but they don't really get into root
causes. One of the big root causes for
plaquing in the arteries, especially
heart attacks, is this thing called
endothelial damage. What is that? You
look at the inside of an artery, there
is this single layer of cells. It's
called the endothelial layer. And when
that becomes damaged, there's a cascade
effect. There's all sorts of
consequences from that. And one of the
first things that happens is you get
inflammation, okay? And then your body's
going to come in and try to repair it.
And that plaque is composed of calcium,
cholesterol, and protein. So realize the
plaque is really a repairerative action
from the inflammation that started
inside your arteries. Now, there's
another little piece of the puzzle and
that is called nitric oxide. When
someone develops endothelial damage to
the inside of the artery, their nitric
oxide goes down and now they lose
control of blood pressure because nitric
oxide helps as a vasod diilator. It
increases more blood flow. And when we
lose that, not only are we going to get
a blood pressure that's going to go up,
we're going to get increased risk of
clotting. And by the way, 90% of heart
attacks involve clots. One of the big
reasons for that is endothelial damage
because now we don't have enough nitric
oxide and that's going to raise our risk
for getting clotting and [clears throat]
that can affect the heart or it can go
up into the brain. We're going to also
get more inflammation, higher blood
pressure. The actual artery wall will
get thicker and stiffer. So there's less
flexibility. There's going to be more
blood pressure problems. And of course
the problem is the doctor is going to
focus on the blood pressure but not do a
lot for this endothelial damage.
Unfortunately what you should know about
nitric oxide is there are natural things
to keep it very very high in the body.
Number one is just being out in the sun.
The sun will give you vitamin D which is
probably one of the most potent things
to increase nitric oxide as well as
infrared. Half of the sun's rays are
infrared. Infrared helps increase nitric
oxide. So there's two things that sun
gives you in relationship to this which
is very powerful. When you breathe
through your nose, you increase nitric
oxide. When you take magnesium, you can
increase nitric oxide. The next thing I
want to talk about is if we're trying to
unclog your arteries. Let's say there is
plaque in the arteries. How does it get
reversed? Well, it just so happens
there's something called RCT, reverse
cholesterol transport. And so there's a
transport mechanism to take the
cholesterol buildup in the arteries and
reverse it and bring it back to the
liver where it's recycled. And just so
you know, this is a really confusing
topic. A lot of times doctors or other
people will tell you that dietary
cholesterol is creating the big problem.
You have to realize that your body makes
most of the cholesterol in your
bloodstream. And so it's a necessary
thing. It's a building block for
hormones. It helps with a lot of things.
But when we're dealing with this problem
right here, it's more late on the chain
of events. It's not an actual root
cause. The things that can help reverse
the cholesterol transport and allow it
to go from the artery back to the liver
is niacin, vitamin B3. Niacin greatly
helps remove cholesterol from the
arteries. HDL that's considered good
cholesterol because it basically takes
the cholesterol from the peripheral part
of the body from the arteries and brings
it back to the liver. Exercise will do
it. Also, fasting, this means not eating
so frequent. And then low carb diets.
Let me just touch on the low carb for a
second. Someone came in and told me,
"Dr. Ber, your program really didn't
work for me. And I said, "Wait a second.
You told me you lost weight. You even
had your cholesterol tested and that was
better. Explain to me why it didn't
work." Well, I tried your low carb diet
for a couple weeks and then I went back
to my normal foods and the problem came
back. So, that was interesting because
so many people have normalized this high
carb diet and unfortunately it is the
opposite of being normal. If you just
take a look at your blood sugar, okay, a
normal blood sugar is 80 milligrams per
milliliter. What does that mean? That
basically is equivalent to one little
teaspoon of sugar in all of your blood.
Whereas you take the average person
who's consuming 45 to 65% of all their
calories being either refined sugars or
refined starches, and starches are
sugar. You're talking about the average
person consuming between 50 to 100
teaspoons of sugar every single day.
Now, that's off of 2,000 calories per
day. And a lot of people have more than
that, so I'm being conservative. But how
can so many people consume so much sugar
yet have normal blood sugar? How can
that be? It doesn't make sense. Well,
that's because sugar is so toxic for
your arteries. It's like something that
goes in there and rusts it out that you
have a protective mechanism that's
called insulin. Insulin comes in there
like a vacuum cleaner and sucks it out
as fast as you put it in there. This is
why so many people can live on so much
carb yet have normal blood sugar because
the insulin is working overtime. Well,
that only happens for about 15 to 20
years before the pancreas is so
exhausted it just can't work anymore. So
at that point our insulin goes lower and
lower and lower and our blood sugar
higher and higher and higher and now the
person goes into a pre-diabetic state
and then a diabetic state. And that's
really what diabetes is. It's a
condition of high sugar in the blood
because insulin can't compensate
anymore. Out of all of the things that
can remove fat from your liver, the low
carb diet is at the top of the list. You
can remove 40% of liver fat within just
14 days if you're on a lowcarb diet. But
the big thing you need to know is all
that refined sugar is being converted
into cholesterol. All that refined sugar
is creating inflammation and creating
endothelial damage starting this whole
cascade of things happening. This is why
it's so important to be on a low carb
diet to keep your nitric oxide super
high. A lot of the excess cholesterol
that you have in your body in your liver
is routed out through help with the bile
salts. So, we need a good amount of bile
to get rid of excess cholesterol. When
people remove their gallbladders,
sometimes they have a problem with
cholesterol building up. So, we need
bile salts to help deal with excess
cholesterol. Couple other points with
calcium in the arteries. Magnesium is
the master controller over calcium. So
the antidote to this calcium problem is
the up your magnesium. Now think about
the arteries. The arteries are
controlled with a muscle. They contract
with calcium and they relax with
magnesium. So if there's any blood
pressure problems, magnesium is a really
important mineral. Polyphenols are very
very powerful in helping protect the
endothelial layer and there's going to
be a very powerful polytheol in the
drink that I'm going to recommend coming
up. Also, vitamin K2. Vitamin K2
actually can help prevent arterial
calcification.
It's the vitamin that takes the calcium
from the soft tissue and keeps it in the
bone and your teeth. Super important. in
helping keeping the arteries healthy.
Now, let's talk about the one drink that
can help you. It's basically using cacao
powder with high flavonoles. Maybe
you've heard of cocoa powder. That is
roasted cacao. So, this is from the raw
bean and this is the stuff that they
make chocolate from. But when you have
this barely refined raw product, you
have a ton of these flavvenols which are
basically plant chemicals that have a
lot of antioxidants and a lot of cool
properties which I'm going to explain to
you. But cacao powder acts just like
exercise in a cup. In one study that
they did, they compared vasoddilation or
blood flow to the artery from cacao
powder and compared that to a medium
exercise and it came out very similar.
And that is because cacao powder is a
potent trigger of this enzyme machine
that helps you make more nitric oxide,
which again is a vasod diilator. It
allows more blood flow to happen. And so
it's just bizarre to me that you could
literally consume something and create
similar effects to exercise. That's just
wild. Now, one of the things that I do
in the morning, I actually put a little
scoop of beetroot juice powder with it.
It adds a really interesting taste. I
like it. But beetroot itself is probably
one of the highest things with nitric
oxide. So, I'm combining two things
together to create an even more powerful
effect. And sometimes I will warm up the
water a little bit, but I will not bring
it to a full boil. But if it's a little
bit warmer, it all mixes a little bit
better. But sometimes I'll have it cold.
But I want to differentiate cacao powder
with beetroot powder. Beetroot powder
actually gives you nitric oxide, okay?
Because there's nitric oxide in here.
Cacao powder actually stimulates the
enzymes in your body to make more nitric
oxide. And I will put that link down
below of that trial. This is the name of
the trial right here that showed the
same dilation as moderate exercise,
which is just mind-blowing. Another
study that I found with cacao powder is
it showed that it reversed arterial
stiffness. Okay, if your arteries are
stiff, right, they're hardened, your
blood pressure is going to be higher.
This usually happens when you age, but
some people are getting it younger and
younger. This is not a good thing. Cacao
powder can help make your arteries less
stiff and make them more flexible.
That's pretty wild. And the cool thing
about cacao powder's effect, as I was
reading through the research, is it's
cumulative. It actually builds up in
your system over time and it can help
teach your arteries to make more nitric
oxide again. So, the effects build on
each other over time. In another study,
and this is pretty wild, they tested
people that were between the age of 50
and 80, and these people consumed cacao
powder on a daily basis for just 14
days. The results in the thickness in
their arteries at this age compared to
people that were 20 to 30 years younger
as far as the thickness goes. I mean,
that's like totally anti-aging on
steroids. And the other thing about
cacao powder, it's not just helping your
heart and your arteries. It's also
helping your brain. It's helping your
skin. It's helping a lot of organs and
tissues in the body. And so, a couple
ways to take this. You can just take it
as is. Mix it in some warm water, drink
it in the morning, but make sure that
it's not at the same time as you're
drinking coffee. Now, sometimes I will
mix it with my coffee, but most of the
time I don't because the caffeine in the
coffee, unless you're doing decaf, can
interfere with the full benefits of
nitric oxide, okay? Because caffeine
tends to vasoc constrict and we're
trying to create a vasoddilation. So,
the best thing to do if you want the
best results, especially for the
arteries, is to have it two hours before
your coffee or two hours after your
coffee. But if you just want more
cognitive benefits, okay, without the
heart benefits, then just put it right
in your coffee. And so sometimes I'll
add the beetroot powder to it, sometimes
I won't. Sometimes I'll add a little
pinch of sea salt or even a little scoop
of magnesium glycinate to get my
magnesium because that's one nutrient
that I really benefit and also it's just
good for the heart. And the last point
is you don't want to put cacao powder in
boiling water. can be in warm water, but
when you have it in boiling water, now
we're heating it up because this is a
raw product. I also recommend if you can
get an organic version, it's just a
little bit better because they use
sprays in certain countries that they
get this from. Anyway, go ahead and try
it and then comment down below of your
results. And if you haven't seen this
video of the best meal to help unclog
your arteries, I put it up right here.
Check it out.